les travaux ont débuté en juillet
dernier la salle jacques brel à montigny
le bretonneux entreprenait de se mettre
aux normes accessibilité pour les
personnes en situation de handicap de la
première phase étant d'ascenseur et puis
après il va s'en suivre une ouverture à
l'intérieur de la salle pour permettre
aux personnes en situation de handicap
de pouvoir entrer par l'entrée
principale mais ensuite pouvoir
bénéficier de cet accès à son sort par
l'intérieur pour accéder en bas de la
salle un ascenseur qui aujourd'hui est
bien visible toute la salle a été adapté
des sièges sont réservés et même la loge
une mise aux normes salariales vraiment
maintenant des définitions le bardage
extérieur là on peut voir delà de la
cage de l'ascenseur un petit peu de faux
plafond et un peu de peinture mais on
est vraiment dans la phase finale
trois cent trente mille euros pour ces
travaux entièrement financé par la ville
qui devrait s'achever au mois de
décembre
une démarche loin d'être isolé depuis
deux ans la ville met aux normes ses
bâtiments
dernier en date l'école charles pays